a starry starry night man just got done
watching a little bit of that James
Blake live on instagrams and man he's a
real Oh you know if you if you pick
James Blake up and you put your ear up
next to him you just man
you could hear a thousand oceans from
different strata spheres man that guy
it's he just if you're not familiar with
his tunes and his you know vocal REE get
out there I mean that guy's got
Siegfried and Roy living inside of his
dang tonsils you know he just he's that
Whistler man I just listened to I was
really listening just now to him on
instagrams and um and it yeah it just
opened up I just dam two of my chakras
fell open
you know he's that pop a lock if your
soul is stalled out on the side of the
uh of the stole of the solar system then
check out some James Blake audio and you
can find him on YouTube and you can find
him in everywhere anywhere you listen to
music you know uh but he just he shows
up and he just got that Jimmy stick and
he'll just I mean who the boy will make
you down he'll make a tea or flow out of
your heart you're like hey I thought we
were just working with blood but next
thing you know you're a orders are
really they slang in salt water you feel
me
so I'm lifted man I feel lifted right
there that's the power of music and it
is quite a power let's get into the
episode gang
[Music]
[Applause]
and that ain't that's not James Blake
that is tiny sand whoo and he just hit
the email opened up yesterday and I
grabbed that email and it was from the
man himself tiny sand whoo and he's been
sending in
Diddy's from the beginning of this
podcast era and that was a cover of by
him for the love of money by The O'Jays
and that's a cover and uh and just nice
of him you know a time when when when
people are really a lot of a lot of us
there's that there's that energy where
you know there's there's just
uncertainty I'm cloaking myself and
uncertainty and here he is saying look
here's a certain tune and this is for
you and I'm gonna give something of
myself and that's tiny sand whoo with
that ear did he man that thing crawling
inside of you hear like a little ant and
he gave us that hit gang I hope you guys
are well I hope you guys are well thank
you for being here I'm here and you are
here and that is a good start you know
that's a good start I'm happy to be
alive today what am i doing I made a
gratitude list this morning you know
just things I'm happy to have arms you
know I'm happy that there's you know
that the calendar works you know imagine
that you got you know the calendar
everybody thinks the calendar just
happened you know like two people were
standing around wondering if there would
ever be a Thursday and then just out of
the sky a calendar just fell and they
said oh dang they got it
somebody graphed it out you know
somebody did the dirty work but a lot of
people don't realize that that yeah the
calendar is basically the calendar is
it's uh well [ __ ] what is it dude the
calendar is like um it's kind of like
the P it's like kind of the honestly
dude it's like kind of a mentally
handicapped periodic table if you look
at it like that like sometimes a
calendar will be outside playing in his
yard and the periodic table will dry by
in a straight-up Corvette you know and
the calendar will be like oh dang boy
honey I'm still on the tricycle you know
I'm not [ __ ] compared to that bad boy
right there so the calendar really is
really a second class set of
organization compared to the big dogs
like the periodic table the food pyramid
what else I am big pentameter different
you know lar different things that are
really more popular kind of I guess you
could say but what are we talking about
man I don't know I don't know anything
man I does anybody you know it's today
it's Monday afternoon the days of the
week are running together you know time
has got I mean things are people are
inside the post mates guys showed up in
the rain last night and it felt like a
damn it felt like I felt like I was in
that movie The Notebook did he showed up
and I just I mean I started it was just
wild I started hearing just romantic
music and he's standing there and he
only had two kebabs for me and I didn't
want him to leave bro because I hadn't
seen it I hadn't singing anybody you
know and I just yelled I said I thank
you for a goddess I'd hide up and he
turned back man and it was it was crazy
in the rain was coming in lightning wow
wow
and he turned back and he goes
and I looked in there and it was in
there and it was in there and uh and I
but when I looked back up from the back
to like acknowledge to him that it was
in there he was gone and man it was just
it was a lot
you know it was a lot and then I'm
sitting in my apartment I'm just one do
I call him back you know do I call him
and say look the site item was in there
but you forgot the silverware bro in the
napkins he forgot that you know but I
just I figured that he kind of said his
piece and I'd said my piece and and I
already given him a tip and we just I
figured I'd just let things be where
they are and leave it in God's hands but
that's how you know it's just people are
starved for attention it's um it's
interesting because it's kind of like a
time where you know on one level it's
like and I'm talking about coronavirus
how if some people don't know what's
going on there is there is a virus that
is try it's attacking people senior
citizens a baby apparent Italians and
Spanish people so those are the ones
really taking an L right now real
heavily they're basically the the
minnesota timberwolves or the Golden
State Warriors of society right now you
know they're the ones having the rut
they're the ones that the that are
really at the bottom so it's um I don't
know I'm talking about I feel nervous
too my chest feels tight I feel nervous
why do I feel nervous
I think of I don't know I think I felt
nervous for a long time I feel like I'm
gonna mess up or something you know I
have to let myself know that I can't
mess up not that I can't but that there
is no messing up you know just be alive
and just you know just just just just
just chill out you know there's no
messing up you know sometimes I'll I
guess I don't know I'm just kind of
feeling this but I always feel like
there's this thing I come in to mess up
I'm gonna mess up I'm gonna mess up and
it just gets exhausting man and it's um
it's not even something I think a lot of
times just something I feel but but I'm
not gonna mess up you know and you're
not gonna mess up it was for a lot of
people out there right now kind of
question what's going on with you know I
know a lot of people are worried about
their jobs and worried about their
finances and worried about what's gonna
happen to them but you know it's
interesting because I think there's
something that happens inside of all of
us or anyway there's something that
happens inside a meter in a time like
this where there's a fear where it's
like okay what am I gonna be okay what's
gonna happen to me what's gonna happen
you know are are they gonna you know is
um are they going to stop allowing
people to do podcasting is there ever
going to be stand-up comedy with crowds
again you know those types of fear
things will get into my head I'm not
saying those are realistic I'm saying
those are fears that will get into my
head but then also there's this other
garden inside of me that says oh how
could I help you know what can I do to
help you know do I have employees are
they worried about their jobs cannot to
communicate with them and say hey you
know we're gonna do everything we can to
to stay to make sure that you know that
we that we bear this together kind of
you know and that I don't just let
you bear this by yourselves or you know
what can you do to call a family member
who's get a thing about who might be
worried about losing their job and you
say hey you know you could come you
could come stay here you know little D
on Drake is sleeping refrigerator will
leave the door open he could sleep in
there at night will unplug it and then
plug it back in during the day you know
so that's so that the cold air won't
kill him at night and he can get a
little bit of rest you know you could
share to bed with me a Victor you know
or me and Horatio or me and AH me and D
me and D or me and uh Denise and they
called her Dee you know there's just
like ways so it's there's two Gardens I
think that go in me and one of them is
like you know one is I'm more of a
garden of fear and one of the more of as
a garden of hope and you know what are
some Joy's I can't embrace in this time
I can I can be a I can be relaxed and I
notice I'll relax a little more
took a nap ha dang boy and I like them
Napa naps dude I like them now I'm a
real Napa dactyl
you'll see me if I'm that Napa dactyl
boy you see me fly through the air and
then just fall asleep and just coast
right in the side of a damn hillside
right into a mountain right into a um
what is it with a things that die that
don't do well in Oklahoma Park
you said I'm saying I'm that Napa dactyl
boy I'm that - can't I'm they call me -
can't Sam I'll be flying through the air
just beautiful color and then I'll just
doze off and just dive bomb into
something you know I'm not sleepy creep
or I like to rest you know it really
resets me so this has been a nice time
to have a little bit of rest you know
since there was something needed here
especially man in America they got us
working or in the world we were working
to get this they got this invisible
wheel going that I'm running on it for
me I felt like I'm right and I'm just
realizing oh man what am I
where I'm trying to keep up with
something that's invisible you know I
mean these are just things I'm thinking
I don't know what I'm talking about I
feel nervous today for some reason and I
think also this that this disease that's
going on this corona virus is a it this
is really a city this is a city this is
in the city you get a different
experience you know in the city you get
okay we need you to stay away from each
other because people can run into each
other people touch each other no freeze
tag you know they got a lot of gay men
sometimes I'll be honest but in the park
by me and this is your I'm not saying
anything you know everybody's probably
gay but I'm saying this this is more
drug induced homosexuality and you know
what I'm talking about you know you play
you know you playing hoops you know
nobody you play hoops with six or seven
guys nobody's gay you play pool with
four or five guys nobody's doing
anything homosexual you know you play
marbles with three of your buddies
nobody's doing anything gay you throw 11
grams of meth into any one of those
games and the whole game ends with
people you know what I'm saying over
time is just a bunch of gay male
activity and that's because of the drugs
think about that think about that man
you know you throw a cut you throw 9
grams of methamphetamines into a into an
Easter into an Easter egg hunt and that
thing hens brought a lot of people you
know a lot of young men for you know
getting nude with each other you know
balance and chocolate on each other's
backs and everything so but what else
are we talking about how I feel so
nervous man
I just feel oh I had a coffee that could
have been it I haven't had a coffee in
probably three weeks I do have an
announcement to them to make I am 23
days off uh no I am 18 days off of
cigarettes I was scared to tell I was
scared to tell people because I'm scared
that if I tell them then I'll start
smoking again you know there's something
sometimes if I tell people what I'm
doing then I won't then I worry that
I'll stop doing it you know or something
I won't take care of myself or whatever
it is but yeah man it's really the one
other one it's one of there's a lot of
bright spots in my life right now you
know when I think about it I made a
gratitude list
[Music]
let me see I've been making them what is
uh and so but but one of the things I'm
grateful for really right now is just
that is that that solitude from
cigarettes the space that I have from
them right now because I don't mind
getting that little Nick a hit or baby
you know I don't mind dousing myself up
with the devil's you know with the
devil's garden with those garden sticks
bro that's all it is bro a cigarettes
just a bunch of dirty salad rolled up
into some paper you know it but it's
nice to to be a little bit separate from
them and get to feel my own vibe running
through my veins sometimes in but what
have I been doing man I've been making
gratitude lists in the morning right now
to help me I'm trying to work on my
gratitude and so that's one thing I've
been doing today I'm thankful I'm not
alone this I'm just reading a couple of
things from my list today
I'm thankful there are people who love
me that are just a phone call away
sometimes I forget that I'll feel like
people don't love me but they do they're
just I got to make enough to meet the
love halfway you know I'm thankful to be
alive and to be amongst other things
that live
so that's one thing I'm thankful for and
um I'm thankful I can read that's a gift
man imagine that you can't read bro
you staring at a bunch of words and you
don't know what it is you don't know if
it's a little zoo you think it might be
a zoo for letters that's fine that's
some people's reality man but I'm
thankful that I know how to decode them
and that's called reading so yeah man
what else is going on what am i what
have I been doing what's been happening
I don't know this weekend oh I went on a
hike yesterday I know a lot of people
are gonna hate hearing that but there's
hike in Los Angeles there's a lot of
hiking so I went out to a solstice trail
and one thing that's nice when you get
out on a hike man I start to want to get
lost honestly you know I'm a big Hansel
and Gretel fan I'm a big Goldilocks fan
you know if you if you if you're out of
town when I was young if you ride a town
and had a couple of bags of uh instant
oatmeal sleeping you I throw on a
[ __ ] yellow wig and I'll Jimmy open
the back door your of your y'all's
complex I'll get into bed you know I'll
have two packets of them instant cheddar
cheese grits and getting a damn bed so
that's it you know I got that little
dirty girl inside of me that like to
live like that that little sleepover
slumber Slutsky you feel me I'm not
afraid to get into somebody else's bed
David I really am NOT I never you know
people used to do hide-and-go-seek at my
friend's house in the first place I go
hide and somebody's better I get right
up in the in that [ __ ] sometimes they
come in the room they're like dan
there's no way do is hiding in grandma's
bed you know and grandma's downstairs
she's you know on the phone she's
bitching at somebody because uh her the
Reader's Digest showed up and it was all
soaking wet and I be laid up in there
you know I have a jaw full of damn maple
brown sugar oatmeal instant and it's
lights out there I'm that kind that's
who I am
you know I'm that I'm that risky I'm
that brave sleeper I'm that that
nocturnal you know what I'm saying I'll
fall asleep with [ __ ] it oatmeal in
my mouth son gang [ __ ] gang [ __ ] boy ah
what am I talking about
I don't know but sometimes that's what
this is man you know what I know it and
I don't know it at the same time I want
to let you guys know that the we had a
live date coming up for the podcast live
in Los Angeles part of Netflix Festival
and that is going to be moved to be
decided date and the Nashville date
April 17th that is probably going to be
moved like literally today it's out of
my control I said let's do it you know I
said I'll do a hologram I'll do a damn
diorama and we'll pass that thing around
you know we'll mail it to each person's
house individually okay you know what
I'm saying get another postage that's
all you need we'll take it for everybody
who who bought a ticket will we got
their address will do postage and damn
BAM hit them with it they get that
diorama with a little audio box next to
it you press the play you look in the
hole
BAM daddy's there but that's not how
they want to do it you know they say
they want to move the date at the Ryman
Auditorium they're in Nashville and and
so that looks like it's going to happen
there will be refunds or whatever is the
scenario and the point of contact they
will let you know that the point of
place you purchased your ticket so I'm
sorry about that it's not me I told him
I said I'll Drive I'll Drive through
everybody yard and yell out a couple
riddles
that's what I told him I'll put re
mantis in the trunk of my car have him
pop out do two or three minutes at each
person's house and we out son with that
roving jokester
but that's not what they want to do so
those are the tour dates right now
that's what's going on with that man I'm
so glad I came in here today and I'm so
glad that you're here and man I'm you
know what I'm just really thankful for
this music right when I came in somebody
sent me a text message they said James
Blake is playing on on live and I went
there and uh starry starry night man if
you if you really you know sometimes I
need other things to get me into a vibe
and I'll do music I'll watch those
videos where you know they surprised the
military dad surprises his kid at school
Jesus man that [ __ ] had me leakin bro
leak and dude I was watching him at
breakfast one time I'd eaten half the
milk out of my cereal bowl did I cried
so much the milk was back up to the top
it was skinned by then but that [ __ ] was
up that [ __ ] was suddenly my honeycombs
was in the deep end again you know man
I'm just grateful to have a perception
that that's feeling okay right now that
I'm not in fear because there's a lot of
people that want to help each other
there's a lot of people that want to be
there for each other and and those are
the people I think we're gonna see the
most during this troubled time
you know it may mean like it's so funny
cuz when you see somebody in person now
you really want to see them you're like
huh what's up what's going on
you know they got on my street they got
a mental fella and this dude is really
I'd say he's five percent mental 95
percent physical you know he wear it
like you don't really have a lot of body
definition and he um he walks a dog you
know when he's out there and you can't
really talk to him he's definitely he's
here physically but he's not really here
like mentally and emotionally you know
he's like the opposite of a hologram
basically like a hologram you get all
the vibe of them but they had to make
the rest of it this dude is you got the
rest of it but the vibe is just is a
vortex you know and uh but when I saw
him yesterday I pulled up I said what's
up what's up you know what's up baby boy
what's up boy hit that horn and he
[ __ ] got a little bit scared but then
he kind of calmed down and he kind of
looked at me for a while and for him
that's really a big step I noticed cuz
he doesn't look at people very much
he really he just walks his dog and kind
of kind of seems scared you know he's
kind of like a boo radley like a like a
thicker kind of boo Riley like kind of a
honey boo boo radley and um but anyway
nice to see his ass and I just felt more
like okay here's a human is a human we
forget and this is all city stuff I'm
talking from a city perspective I live
in a city in a rural area man I think
this [ __ ] is just pretty chill this is
just the devil playing hiding this is
just the devil playing freeze tag with a
lot of seniors so
so that's what's up man um have me a
little drink right there a little hit of
something but yeah what else is going on
I am purchasing a weapon I got a gun on
the way everybody knows I got that six
gauge and I got me a um I think it's
like a sharpshooter v7z 71 or something
double-barrel pretty much and I think
it's even why I got one of the ones you
load you load from the front so you know
somebody you want to pay the piper if
they come piping but anyway yeah you got
some of you if I say get him do have a
weapon do have something to take care of
yourself it could be anything you don't
have to have a gun you don't have to
have a cannon you know you wheel that
[ __ ] I don't know the porch and light
it and you don't set any stockades
behind it or bricks up under the back
tires and that [ __ ] just the recoil
blows right in your damn living room you
know sends you you send your cousin
straight to heaven you got a hat you
know what I'm saying you kept incurring
air you do a trip wire you know you do
that gay wombat were you hanging from
the bottom of a tree when somebody comes
by glitter I'm right in the face bro and
then tickle them until they admit that
they might be interested in men bro even
if there's no drugs so you got to
recognize that everybody has a different
type of weapon that they can get but I'm
not saying run around with a weapon but
I'm saying I'm saying it's never a bad
idea I don't think to have the
opportunity to protect yourself if
you're in an area that needs protection
you know if you live next to a Domino's
Pizza you're probably gonna be fine
because when pizzas around everybody
seems pretty calm so
but yeah it's hard tough time to get
some things you know you know it's a
tough time to get to um you know a 12 of
eggs if you want it or get you a jar of
milk or a pack of booty Kleenex but the
hardest thing to get a hold of right now
is a senior citizen for real they got
them locked up right now
okay if you want a senior citizen guess
what you can barely get one I'm serious
try and find a senior citizen try and
play a game of hide and go senior
citizen there you're gonna end up with
nothing
you want a graham cracker great you want
a gram mother fat chance
little Randall I mean you got to go to
the dark web really you got to go to a
dark alley you'll see somebody in the
distance being like a man you know where
I could get up you know where I could
get a Ethel or surely a Betty a Joyce a
Henry a Howard a Harold a Royce not a
meemaw a Mimi
a Grampy a pop-pop your search for an ad
where Leto must stop it's true you want
out you wanna um you want a recipe you
want an old story huh you want a
black-and-white picture of somebody
dressed up like they're in the military
from a long time ago
fat chance you want a ceramic frog
that's part of a larger collection what
are you gonna get it you want somebody
to pull a fake quarter from behind your
ear now right now bucko
you can't find a senior citizen right
now you can't find one you wanna uh you
want a musty smell during a hug huh
you want a replica tea cup from the
Titanic autograph by um Abraham
Lincoln's cousin bra fat shunts
I'm just saying the hardest thing to
come across right now is that SC baby
that senior sit
Zen breath oh man come on you go to a
man who you got in there me ain't got no
buddies here man no we ain't got no
Ethel's man we ain't got no mr. Harold's
we ain't got no Hank senior we're not
man we don't we don't have oh no we
don't have any Gertrude in here you got
the wrong place buddy get to steppin but
I saw a walker parked in the front yard
that's nothing man that's nothing
times have changed buddy you want to
hear arm affable
you want to hear you want to hear
somebody talk about Audrey Hepburn not
today not today son you want to see an
adult that only eats real soft food out
of a blender
not today bucko you want to see somebody
that makes a lot of noise when they put
their pants on bro you want to see
somebody that could take a nap dude for
no reason at all not today buddy
you want an Eightball that's easy you
want an 88 year old male mm-hmm I don't
think so son keep it moving
it's just a tough it's a tough it's a
tough time to get a senior that's what
I'm saying man
and we got to keep them safe man and
it's kind of nice isn't it it's kind of
nice for the seniors suddenly or a heart
or eartha or the they're the gold
they're the gold man they're the diamond
you got to protect them then if you're
good to want to protect your family
doesn't it feel good to call it check in
with your grandparent let them know hey
I got you you know I still don't I can't
come visit you now at least a lot of
people I can't come visit you now
because well you know it's an excuse at
least I haven't visited for for four
years but I still can't come huh so but
I love you and that's all they want a
lot of times seniors they want to call
from you
I got to let you know today's episode
and support for this past weekend comes
from manscaped manscaped
it's the number one in men's
below-the-belt grooming we could use
support for this podcast if you need to
take care of your junk you need to
tighten it up because look we may be
going back to caveman times in our
society but that doesn't mean you have
to be that way in your pants manscaped
offers precision-engineered tools for
your family jewels
look I've taken care of my balls and I'm
taking care of my nuts and wiener
throughout my life and the area around
my thighs brother I like them [ __ ] I
put a little polish on them and stuff at
night a little soft polish bra you know
what I'm saying a little something I put
out on the UM on the couch a little wide
Wiedeman sweetens I'm putting you know
two dabs of that and some tan polish on
them sometimes you know I got to darken
up that gap maybe you feel me I like
that I like my thigh gap dark but
everybody takes care of their body
differently manscaped is forever
changing the grooming game with her
perfect package 2.0 inside the perfect
package you'll find the electric trimmer
called the lawn mower this thing's great
you could bend over and just completely
mow do that straight up mow from you
newts to your damn ass you can create
less mess by trimming in the shower even
now that's beautiful you tired of being
out there trim and leaving it in on the
floor hiding it under the mat you know
sometime you'll even trim your crotch
and get the all the hair and just brush
it into the dog's fur blame it on the
dog oh he's shedding over there look at
him he's nasty it's time to get clean
with this perfect package 2.0 it also
includes anti chafing performance boxer
briefs that keep your package cool and
smelling fresh all day get 20% off and
free shipping with the code Theo th EO
at manscaped com always use the right
tools for the job your balls will thank
you think about your balls man we're in
a tough time get 20% off and free
shipping with the code th EO at manscape
com that's 20% off with free
shipping at manscaped dot-com and use
the code Theo th e oh we had some
beautiful calls that came in let's get
into a few of them we had that intro
sent in by tiny sand whoo I'm hot off of
those James Blake wrists if you need
something to open up your heart in this
time man those James Blake riffs really
do do it for me and uh it's just it's
like somebody I can't even explain it
man you know some people are instruments
on the earth that God uses or or
whatever higher power you believe in
uses and and that man has been one of
those instruments within them let's take
some calls here we go yo cos guys are
willing to call and tell you happy
birthday learn Oh Thank You jasmine I
appreciate that man yeah I'm getting to
be an adult brother I'm getting to be an
adult in a sweetie you to make that
message man and uh yeah dude Jasmine
that's a beautiful name that's a unique
name that's a name of a rice as well
jasmine rice and that's or a mixed girl
even so that's you know a couple of
beautiful creations right there homeward
it's a big day and I also had a question
for you man so with this coronavirus
going and going around we're all
quarantine then so how are you keeping a
thick is your a personal trainer give
you any any workouts to keep that uh
that booty thick or or is there some
secret service you're holding Carmen
trying to find out man no I don't want
to get small helping me out
oh man I'm doing look I got a the
trainer I was seeing I'm still seeing
her on the DL and she you know they got
a little training speakeasy going on
they got the windows boarded up but you
slip in through the side and next thing
you know you kettlebell in you know next
thing you know you drinkin some you know
they got a water machine and you get in
water and struggling in between the
water times you're allowed to drink and
it's beautiful man um so I'm doing that
I'm taking this week off I believe to
focus on yoga and rolling out my body
you know I really want to take advantage
of my physical body while I still can
while I still have this vessel
you know I want to be able to do
everything I can physically still so so
I'm trying to stay active and fit I've
been running two and a quarter miles two
and a quarter stars
I've been running two and a quarter
miles and getting that big 2/4 in and uh
and focusing on some yoga and rolling my
body out I'm that tight white but my
body gets real conjoined during the
center you know I'm built like a damn
junior bread man
so I'm sweet but I'm you know it's hard
to get the arms and leg you can't do a
lot of stuff you know what I'm saying
I've always had limited reach limited
look ability in my neck if I hear
something behind me don't even give a
[ __ ] anymore that's where I'm at with my
dexterity so I used to be that owl you
know I spent I [ __ ] spin around I did
they used to call me Tony Hawk of the
dam upper vertebrae I'd do a 760 on the
dam just being curious with something
behind me but that's changed man so I'm
staying a little bit busy with training
man I appreciate you asking though and I
appreciate you thinking about me and
asking about my birthday man I'm happy
to be alive
and I'm happy that I was born you know
I'm happy that my mother had me and I'm
happy that my father had me um you know
I have a lot of gifts in my life I'm
happy that I can feed myself today I'm
happy that um you know that I have a
roof over my head you know and I and I
know I'm just saying things that are
pretty normal but I'm trying to really
get these things in my life where they
fit where I feel them inside of myself
so I'm trying to work on them everyday
right now and really have some gratitude
and and I and I'm you know I'm happy
that I'm able to love people and I'm
able to feel loved you know it's real
hard for me sometimes to do that man I
don't know why I'm so nervous today it
could have been that coffee but what a
gift man what a little you know some
little gifts I'm happy that I have
brothers and sister
that I know that love me you know and
and and just that I had the ability to
care about people what a what a crazy
gift that is inside of us like what if
we just saw people and you know animals
are beautiful but I don't know if they
can love each other I saw two [ __ ]
Ravens beating the [ __ ] out of each
other earlier by abandoned pumpkin patch
over there off the 170 so I'm just
saying that we got some beautiful gifts
let's take some more calls man gang
what up Co Nick I just wanted to say
yeah what's up Nick thank you for
calling man I appreciate that and that's
a unique name to have Nick you know we
got our producer premature Nick and he's
really doing well for somebody that I
mean he's always been a little skidded
he came out there you know that dude
came out the womb early as hell and he
had on the damn cumberbund when he
showed up that dude was ready to rock
you know he got into the world early so
he's always you know he's the first to
draw that pistol man and it's just
people playing Simon Says so it's you
know he has some risky hand uh you know
some brain hand movements but but he's
one of a kind and um anyway onward
thanks for being you man and being
positively I'm trying man I'm trying bro
we're all trying man but it's the only
it's the only thing that's gonna help us
it's the only thing that's good you know
it's the only thing that's good thank
you for calling what else being funny
you know I'm the funny guy here in my
town where I live and my family friends
and everything oh then you could have
had my job man cuz you just got to be
that and then you got to go take it out
it's out of town that's all it is man so
we probably are very similar let's hear
more and I know the heavy burden and you
know a lot going on out there in the
world debate and it's scary and I've got
two kids one with asthma mm-hmm
and I'll worry about it it seems Rogen I
named him after Joe believe it or not
man thanks I can listen to you and block
it all out gang bruh well thank you man
that's sweet of you to say that to me
man uh you know it's I'm just the I'm
just part of this group and but yeah I
could imagine if you have a son you know
and you have a child who's dependent
upon you and and there's something in
the air that you know you can't control
you know the feeling of that kind of the
helplessness of it a bed is really
really tough to have on your chest and
have on your heart a lot of times so
thank you for sharing that with us man I
know that really puts it in perspective
for me a little bit yeah this is and
it's such a crazy thing just to think we
breathed something in or we take it in
you know you know and here you created
this you know young creature does
beautiful little fella this little rogue
and then you got him running around and
he gots that asthma brah he's got them
damp lungs that's what it is and we know
it you cuz you know you google it right
now you see a picture of a long with a
little bit of uh you know the the
condenser isn't working on it but um but
but it sounds like you know if you have
a sense of humor man I bet that's into
something nice for him to have around
because even a wet Lunken damn laugh you
know we used to have a buddy growing up
and he would leak out of the sides of
his mouth this boy Summerall and Jesus
man he what the hell was going on with
him but um but uh he had like kind of I
guess I asked - tongue or something you
know he had that or he was just like a
damn uh he was much more like a damn
what's that
let me google this dog that dog that uh
slobbers a lot
he had that damn uh the internet is slow
huh
now that's something they got about at
least corvid six in this damn Internet
yeah I don't know this dude he you know
he was like one of them show dogs and
mountain dogs then water faces man like
a water more honor you know what I'm
saying just dripping out the front like
somebody left the false at home and it's
boy Sumrall and uh and he's alive and
doing well man is what I'm trying to say
and so I'm sure just happen you having a
sense of humor it brings it brings a lot
of light into your son's life man and
and him having that light and energy and
him that's gonna keep him that's gonna
keep him so much healthier than anything
else I bet you could ever imagine you
know I know there's people on for myself
and even just listening to the music
today from that artist man before I
started this podcast today I I was more
nervous I don't know what I'm nervous
about
just anxiety there's stuff in the air I
don't know but man I heard that music
and it just changed my heart
it changed my brain and it just so you
know those are the instruments that I
think God uses man you know or higher
power boot or whatever whatever kind of
God you run it on you know god almighty
whatever Jim Carrey whatever you whoever
you know whoever's torquing your engine
but but yeah man I bet having a dad like
you is definitely helping keeping
keeping the water out of his lungs man
so you guys stay stay dry over there and
just keep it classy man everything's
gonna be fine and thanks for sharing
some sentiment with us man that goes a
long way mmm you know just reminded it
just puts me in a place where you know
when I'm reminded of humanity or
something that makes me feel it like
it's almost like it's like my feelings
my body just gets set onto a thing like
a bed or something I just feel calm so
thank you brother let's get a call right
here they came in nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three is the
hotline and I'd love to know for next
week what are the things that are
affecting you guys with the virus like
what do you what are your thoughts you
know what are your fears are you scared
are you doing okay you know what are
your what are the thoughts of people in
America what are you thinking what do
you you know I know the news gives us a
lot of information and too much
information sometimes and sometimes very
you know information that's not really
for us you know it has a different
purpose
fear tactical but I know there's a lot
of factual stuff out there as well and I
know it is a time where we have to take
care of ourselves and what's going on
with you let me know man leave a
voicemail and uh we're gonna get into
that next week here we go still big fan
of you big fan of the podcast you know
with everything going on in the world
right now and especially in the country
with coronavirus I thought maybe you
know to lighten the mood I would write a
little song you know plain white teeth
hey there Delila the song I was a parody
connect so I changed the very key made
it my own as well hey there corona I'm
gonna sing it for you acapella okay so
okay we got a we got a little canary
right here just fella and he said um
he's gonna do it for us he's gonna do a
song for us so thank you buddy
thank you buddy buddy and you got this
song you got that hitter stuck in your
throat he's about to serve it from hey
there Delilah Delilah - hey
Korona let's hear that hit I don't have
the greatest toys but I did drink honey
tea recently and I've had a couple of
potato chips to soften the oldie sauce
advice okay so he had a couple of honey
teas and he had a sausage
so yeah sausage that grease sometime
will ah that'll sweeten your pipe bro
you know what I'm saying that'll let up
I don't [ __ ] you'll you'll have a
just a cease a cease a a c-flat just fly
to your throat on accident you know
you'll be talking to somebody and just
let's hear it gang here we go mm-hmm
hey there corona I heard it's bad in New
York City first you got Tom Hanks Arita
don't you dare go for P Diddy that'd be
cruel now the kids got two weeks off to
school that two weeks this year they
gave him two years now I think
dude they got one kid he's it one day I
saw an 8 year old he said he's never
[ __ ] going to school he told me and
somebody go [ __ ] myself and he
misspelled [ __ ] he wrote it down so he
really needs the education as the
saddest part homework that ain't cool
hey there Corona you ain't nothing but a
virus your name makes me want a cold one
but we don't want you inside us not at
all and now we can't go through them all
till next fall oh you've got us
Florentine though you've got us
quarantined oh you've got us Florentines
oh you've got us for a change a couple
weeks seems pretty bad to be cooped up
with mom and dad were running out of TP
as we speak Verona I can promise you
this was not like the Spanish flu but my
social life will never be the same
that's true people suddenly crotches
down around this time you can't even get
somebody to show you their their body
aim homeward and get a bang hey there
Corona once we finally get past if we
can go back to our life and we can start
to wipe our asses like we do oh this has
been because of you but I know we're
gonna make it for
or pay their Carolla here's to you this
one's for you oh you've got us
Florentine oh you've got us quarantined
oh you've got us quarantined oh you've
got us quarantined [ __ ] God that's
cool and he stay safe out there gang man
thank you brother
look at you just serving that thing bro
that dirty canary just landed on you on
your leg with a broken wing and you
tickle him and he spits up that hit
right that's beautiful praise God daddy
there you go hey there corona and hey
there Delila I think what is that back
originally I think that might be a back
hit if you listen to music or not
alright let's take one more call right
here we got a lot we got a lot of great
ones coming up over the next couple of
episodes and we got big baby Glen Davis
coming in here and I'm real curious to
see what uh what's going on with that
gentleman and he's from he went to play
basketball down there in Baton Rouge
Louisiana and he's a big man and I've
always been a regular man so just that
you know to have the blue you know like
if him he looks at a ski he looks at
skiing and he thinks oh I could probably
like I let people do that on my back if
I want it but me I don't look at it like
that I look at it as something that's
hard to do okay let's take another call
that came in right here
homework hi feeling this this is aunt
[ __ ] and grandma calling for central
Illinois we didn't know if you had run
out of soap and fragrance oh yeah if you
did we might need to send you some more
Thanks what's up man Vicki and grandma
out of central Illinois huh yeah you
guys sent us a lot of beautiful hair
lotion and different body potion
underarms scent underarm sense thank you
very much
I'm still using a lot of the lotion I'm
still using the hair polish I'm still
using um what else a lot of that tall
sandalwood scented um
a body sauce or something you know few
my what does it call few my humor
cologne so thank you so much for that no
I still got about another probably 240
ounces of cologne to go through so I
mean my neighbors are pissed did I
forget sprayed the whole carpet with it
so I'm good right now on that um no but
this sweet of you a sweet of you to
think of me you know the sweet of you
just to think of anything you know and
to call in and think about me right now
and how I'm smelling and how my body my
skin is doing um you know that's
thoughtful of you so thank you you know
I have some some of the stuff I have too
much of it even so maybe I'll give it
some to the king and the stain guys and
girls over there but no that's so sweet
Evie I don't know if I've even got to
call you and thank you for that I know
we talked about it on the the anthrax
challenge but but we're actually we're
gonna do another anthrax challenge I got
some birthday gifts that are coming here
from different people and thank you so
much and I just think it's a good time
to get is just a nice thought like who
cannot call now and think okay who can I
help what can I do for somebody how can
I be of assistance you know what can I
do what do I have that somebody else
might need you know maybe I got an extra
$100 what is it do it for me you know if
I know somebody's losing their job it's
kind of funny because suddenly like
money is you know and look I'm fortunate
enough I have enough money to get me
through the month you know but it's
funny like suddenly it's like having
stuff seems greedy more so than ever a
little bit if you know that other people
aren't going to have stuff
so yeah what a time for us to really get
inside of ourselves and call others you
know call a young fella you know where a
young woman and say hey how can I you
know let me mail you a thing a soap let
me you know let me send you a thing of
apple cider you know I'm saying let me
email you uh you know or let me you know
let me overnight you a couple grams a
Tillamook cheddar or something let me do
something let me [ __ ] cut you off a
little half a handful of summer sausage
over there you fill your palm up you
know grease your palm with actual grease
meat let me do something for you let me
give you know let me give you me let me
give you a bagful of uh you know lime
slices do something for somebody here's
a cut of lime brah you know let me brush
your teeth for you come over here let me
brush your teeth for you you relax you
know it's that time of year where it's
that's that time of life you know it's
interesting it's interesting that we're
in this time right now and this is an
opportunity for us to think about yeah
how can I help this person what can I do
something little and it's not like hey
here I'm giving you something just hey
how are you doing what's going on you
know and also to be brave enough for us
to let other people know if we were
struggling and if we're scared you know
that's hard for me to do a lot of times
I have a tough time when it comes to the
communication of if I'm scared you know
or like I do just yesterday I was
wondering like man I wonder what my mom
is feeling like has she been scared
would she tell me if she was you know
cuz seniors man that's the hidden that's
the real
we got to hide them bro put your
granddaddy in a safe dude you know what
I'm saying
you know what I'm saying set me mo on a
mousetrap somebody goes to get her BAM
they doesn't you know it's time we got
about we got to lock him up you know
hide your grandma hide your grandpa cuz
Corvin 19-day out here and they you know
they geeking out they getting people
that thing will show up like little
Daniel Brown [ __ ] break out all you
all the windows and your lungs dude and
say he didn't do it you did it
you know you did it um I got to go to an
AAA meeting man honestly that's from
going so I love you guys thank you for
having me in your life today thank you
for being in my life today try and keep
your heads up I know maybe I'm you know
it's easy for me to talk sometimes I
know that I can you know I have a you
know my rent is paid for the month and
you know and I have money to go to the
grocery store this week so I know maybe
I sound you know I might sound like I'm
coming from a perspective that other
people aren't coming from I don't know I
don't know everybody's life but but uh
but I just I hope that everyone just
stays positive as they can you know I'm
saying we got this [ __ ] bro we got this
dude corvid 19 they're getting better
better come back with the remix dude
ain't going down at at Korver 30 Corvis
60 none of us getting me Corvus 7000
maybe maybe I start to struggle I pulled
an 8 off on my chest and throw that
bastard you know I'll break out that
freaking six gauge that's seven gauge
but you know I'll do that bow and arrows
pot I'll son Cupid dude you in love dude
and now you're done now you're done son
so stay alive baby be good to yourselves
you deserve it lets you move out here
with a little bit of north
mississippi allstars and and they got
this hit for us right here and this
thing is called drunk outdoors and they
their supporters and they've been
awesome and they beautiful group they've
been playing for so long if you want to
check out some other good music that'll
put you in a good vibe I will put a link
to them below in the youtubes and that
is off they're up and rolling album the
North Mississippi Allstars
[Music]
destroy
go get your outdoors
dancefloor
the throw get drunk outdoors
and they made a special one just for us
I'll play it next week cooking with gas
on
dog
let's go get drunk out dog
[Music]
[Applause]
if you feelin lonely man love somebody
the way out of ourselves is is through
somebody else man I believe that you
know and I don't always do it but I do
believe that it's there's truth in
[Music]
thank you guys may be good to yourselves
mean you guys deserve it we all deserve
it and let's stay in the light baby we
got this gang